[موسيقى]
نحن في أورلاندو بولاية فلوريدا ، نحن في
منطقة جنوب شرق الحرم الجامعي لرفاق الكلاب ،
نحن أكبر وأقدم
منظمة تقدم كلاب خدمة
للأطفال البالغين والمحاربين القدامى
ذوي الإعاقة ونعمل
بجد لتغيير حياة
[الموسيقى]
التي نقدمها  عدة أنواع مختلفة من الكلاب
أحد أنواع الكلاب التي نقدمها
هو كلب خدمة يعمل كلب الخدمة
مع شخص ما للتخفيف من
إعاقته يمكنه التقاط أغراض فتح وإغلاق
أبواب الأدراج ثلاجات
[موسيقى
] يمكن للكلاب معرفة أكثر من 40 أمرًا.
نريد أن تحب الكلاب العمل الذي يقومون به
[موسيقى]
منذ عام 1975 ، وضعنا أكثر من 7200 كلب ،
لدينا حاليًا أكثر من 2600
خريج يعملون مع
كلاب خدمة لمنظمتنا وأكثر من 1400
مربي جرو هم  إن تربية
الجراء لنا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
هي مجرد وقت سحري
[موسيقى]
إنه بالنسبة للكثيرين
منهم اللحظة التي ينتظرونها ،
لذا قدمنا ​​طلبًا أريد أن أقول عام
ونهاية  قبل ذلك ، علمنا أن هذا هو
الشيء الصحيح لأنه كان
يدخل المستشفيات وخارجها بسبب سرطان
الدماغ وجميع المرافق التي كنا فيها
بها كلاب علاج وهم يجلبون
الكثير من الفرح للأطفال القدرة على تقديم
إنها ليست رفيقة فحسب ، بل
رفيقة ماهرة يمكنها المساعدة في بعض
التحديات التي نواجهها يوميًا لتخفيف
بعض الضغط عنها
والاختلافات الجسدية التي كانت لديها عندما كانت طفلة تبلغ
من العمر 10 سنوات وتستخدم
مشاية ستكون مجرد  تغيير اللعبة في
الأماكن العامة بالنسبة لنا ، أعتقد
أنني أرسم ولاعة على
الكثير وقد ساعدوني في اختيار ذلك
[موسيقى]
نحن نقدم كل الكلاب لدينا
مجانًا بفضل التبرعات المذهلة
، أعني أن فواتيرنا الطبية لا بأس بها  عالية ،
لذا فهي حقًا هدية لعائلتنا ،
نريد التأكد من أن أي شخص
يحتاج إلى كلب خدمة أو كلب مرفق
يمكنه الحصول على
[موسيقى]
ثم في نهاية
فصل التدريب الجماعي سيقيمون حفل تخرج
حيث سيتخرجون ويذهبون
الوطن
اليوم هو رفقاء الكلاب ،
يوم التخرج الوطني ، بدلاً من الحصول على دبلوم ،
سيتم تسليم خريجينا اليوم
مقودًا كما تعلمون فقط ليس المجهول
[تصفيق]
والمجهول يجلب
أسئلة تهانينا
لكن Aurora ستكون ثابتة لـ Izzy
حسنًا
[موسيقى]